merci à Rachel Richard et Patrick d'être
avec nous
non
[Rires]
rigole un petit peu vous détendre un
petit peu racontez-nous qui peut nous
raconter ce qui s'est passé qui prend la
porte Ludovic je laisse commencer
Olivier vas-y Olivier
en gros notre patron le 9
août il a appelé pour lui dire d'ouvrir
la porte à Ludovic pour qu'il puisse
aller faire la mise en place donc elle
est montée lui a ouvert et moi je suis
arrivé à 10h et c'est Ludovic qui a reçu
deux trois messages de
notre patron pour lui dire qu'il allait
à l'hôpital ou comme quoi et tout c'est
du sang et ainsi de suite et
[Musique]
quelques derniers messages qu'on a reçu
de lui on a reçu en soi-disant message
de l'infirmière qui disait comme quoi
elle allait dans le coma pendant une
douzaine d'heures vous avez pensé que
c'est une fausse infirmière qui vous a
appelé bah par message ouais c'est un
peu un message
sur le téléphone de Ludovic donc c'est
un peu bizarre quoi en général ça
rappelle la première qui vous écrit qui
va être c'est ça en fait une infirmière
qui m'envoie un une soi-disant
infirmière qui m'envoie un message
depuis son le téléphone de mon patron du
coup et me disant comme quoi il serait
plongé dans un coma pendant 12 heures et
une infirmière n'en voit pas comment ça
c'était le 9 août ouais donc même
pendant 12 heures bon le 10 août
normalement et vous avez de ses
nouvelles ouais c'est ça oui depuis mais
donc toujours pas de nouvelles
du jour au lendemain et vous êtes dans
le bar saison c'est le seul propriétaire
non d'accord
je vous ai envoyé un sms je suis pas là
pendant 24 heures
et donc
vous faites quoi vous êtes obligé de
retourner et vous continuez à travailler
on est obligé de retourner travailler
parce que sinon c'est une un abandon de
poste et on perd nos salaires mais je
comprends pas parce que qui alors qui
vous fait des salaires qui vient prendre
la question ce soir c'est ça qu'on a les
questions mais les fournisseurs qui les
payent ça les fournisseurs ne sont pas
payés en fait on ne peut plus on peut
plus avoir de matériel d'accord et
fournisseurs ne veulent plus nous donner
matériel parce que il y a il y a des
impayés et ils savent que le patron est
parti aussi en fait on fait on travaille
pas on fait acte de présence on se met à
la disposition du patron il y a des
clients ou pas non il y a pas de clients
toute la journée au restaurant
on passe le temps quoi
[Musique]
alors c'est c'est fou parce que vous
pouvez pas vous pouvez faire quoi vous
pouvez pas fermer le restaurant vous
êtes obligés d'être là sinon ça abandon
de poste mais la question que je pose
comment vous êtes payé vous vous n'êtes
pas payé vous n'avez pas non donc vous
êtes là-bas vous êtes pas payé vous mais
vous êtes obligés d'y aller quand même
et oui mais si vous n'êtes pas payé vous
êtes pas obligé d'y aller non alors on
sait on est on serait pas obligé de
venir bah c'est ça mais on préfère venir
parce qu'on a en ces rapprocher d'avocat
etc et ils nous ont conseillé de venir
par par sécurité parce que c'est une
situation qui a jamais été vue donc
c'est incroyable cette histoire parce
que donc le patron il vous dit 9 août je
vais subir je suis pas bien vous recevez
un SMS d'une soi-disant l'infirmière qui
vous dit il va être dans un pendant une
opération pendant 12 heures plus de
nouvelles qui était le plus proche de du
patron c'était vous lui donnes
mais vous avez senti un truc il avait
l'air déprimé il était pas bien il sait
quoi son but non il était pas déprimé il
était pas dépressif ou quoi que ce soit
ce qu'on dit nous ça nous est tombé
comme ça dessus vous avez pas remarqué
un comportement bizarre chez lui
pas plus que d'habitude il a pas de
famille
alors on a contacté sa famille mais sa
famille c'est pareil personne n'est au
courant nous on a appelé j'ai appelé ça
sa fille et sa fille n'était même pas au
courant de la situation elle a pas de
nouvelles non plus non alors vous dites
on aurait écrit une motivation
fluctuante ces derniers mois pas
comparable avec à son entrée pour se
resservir à la tireuse à bière
donc c'est ça il y a moins de motivation
ouais beaucoup moins de motivation ces
derniers temps ouais mais est-ce qu'on a
une idée d'où il est venu parce que si
on se fie d'où il est parti parce que si
on se fait aux affiches aux avis aux
notes publiés sur le restaurant il avait
l'air de bien tourner le restaurant
elles sont contents du reste était
content du restaurant oui les gens
mangeaient étaient contents ils
mangeront on mangeait très bien aller au
restaurant marchait bien il fait du
profit au début oui au début moi sur la
fin
et après on ne savait pas exactement ce
qu'il y avait il y a eu ce qu'il y avait
comme marge ou pas mais il habite loin
de chez vous ou pas non non on habite
tout seul
on a été chez lui pas de news non
zéro il avait il avait une compagne il
avait une compagne ouais aucune aucune
nouvelle fin de elle on a des nouvelles
mais je veux dire on n'a pas de
nouvelles du patron quoi la gendarmerie
elle vous a dit quoi parce que là mine
de rien on commence à s'inquiéter aussi
pareil du bureau au lendemain on a pas
de news pour eux pour la gendarmerie
c'est tout simplement une disparition
volontaire d'accord aucun signe
d'inquiétude le téléphone a borné dans
la Drôme à borné à Montpellier bon selon
les gendarmes pas d'enquête à ouvrir il
est parti de son plein gré pour changer
de vie comme 20000 personnes chaque
année en France donc il s'est barré dans
la nature et donc ni le procureur ni
l'administration ni l'inspection du
travail ne peuvent faire quoi que ce
soit pour le moment la situation est
surréaliste oui mais oui mais sur un
moment quand il se passe un truc comme
ça en fait il peut pas y avoir de
licenciement économique par exemple le
propriétaire mais vous pourriez
démissionner demander un huissier de
constater saisir le conseil des
prud'hommes
alors ce qu'on est en train de faire
justement c'est qu'on a saisi le
procureur pour que lui puisse l'amener
au courant de la situation et on
[Musique]
c'est pour ça qu'il faut attention à pas
commettre de fautes que l'avocat les
consommateurs
est-ce que c'est vrai que au moment des
des appels juste avant sa disparition et
vous a promis que les salaires à aller
arriver dans quoi il m'a dit le 10 août
le 10 j'ai eu le 9 au matin à 10h30 il
m'a dit le 10 août je te les averses
sont là sur ton compte et je lui dis
ouais mais moi mes prélèvements c'est le
5 et tout ce qu'il y a et il me dit
ouais c'est pas grave je te paierai les
les remboursements d'agir aussi mais il
y a toujours rien on est le je sais
qu'il y a une urgence pour vous un en ce
moment la financièrement c'est compliqué
là je sais pour vous trois
jours par jour et après on verra quoi et
tu vas quand même au travail
en plus du temps
quelles sont les solutions pour euh il
faut que le procureur effectivement se
saisisse de l'affaire il faudrait qu'il
liquidation mais ça prend du temps donc
les recours sinon c'est les assurances
mais encore faudrait-il que le
restaurant Le patron soit assuré pour le
moment c'est le vide total c'est pour ça
que cette situation est complètement
inédite dans l'Est de la France on n'a
jamais vu ça c'est même pas si c'est
arrivé des gens en France c'est
totalement surréaliste de partir comme
ça sans donner la moindre nouvelle alors
on dit aussi que il avait peut-être des
problèmes d'argent de trésorerie vous
avez entendu parler de ça ou pas on a
nous on se doute bien qu'il y avait
quelque chose mais on n'a aucune
certitude on ne sait pas parce qu'il y a
eu de l'argent il est rentré en fait
après on peut partir sur plein
d'hypothèse et dire plein de choses
qu'on a imaginé dans notre tête c'est
quoi les choses que vous avez imaginé
qu'il a pris la caisse il a mis que le
qu'il a mis que le tout ce qui vit en
quartier de crédit sur le compte on a
imaginé plein de choses mais on ne sait
rien on a aucune certitude on peut pas
savoir oui habituellement vous étiez
payer en temps et en heure les autres
mois ou il y avait toujours du retard en
général on le sait qu'on l'avait et le
mois dernier avant le mois de juillet
donc au mois de juin le mois de juin
aussi ça le mois de juin c'est déjà venu
trois jours en retard ok mais sinon vous
aviez pas de quoi vous inquiéter
un peu c'est un peu de vous détendre un
peu mais c'est vrai que c'est une
situation très compliquée pour vous en
plus le propriétaire du camping dans
lequel se trouve le restaurant parce
qu'ils seront dans un camping avec
conclu un bail de location-gérance dans
2019 avec le giron il dit que les
factures non réglées s'accumulant les
électricité devrait bientôt être coupé
ça donc vous allez faire quoi vous allez
rester dans le noir dans le restaurant
attendre que après l'hiver arrive et
puis on fera un feu de camp peut-être de
l'autre côté ah c'est c'est fou alors on
rappelle les dernières nouvelles il
aurait donc dit à Ludovic il vous l'a
dit où il voulait écrit il me l'a écrit
vous avez les urgence à Colmar car il
vomissait du son ouais ensuite il a reçu
un message où il était écrit qu'il
serait placé comme maladie dans le coma
pendant 12 heures et plus rien Gilles
c'est quoi l'hypothèse parce que est-ce
qu'il est parti avec la caisse c'est ça
aussi de volontaire de difficulté
financière qui serait je crois le
conditionnel qui serait caché et puis
d'un propriétaire qui aurait été englué
sans le dire sous les dettes et qui
serait parti donc pour changer de vie ce
qui est très étonnant c'est ni ça finit
sa compagne en nouvelle non plus donc à
la fois le changement professionnel
l'abandon du restaurant et le changement
de vie personnelle radical donc voilà
mais ça fait furieusement penser à une
disparition volontaire de quelqu'un qui
veut changer de vie et se donner de
l'air voilà alors le conseil des
prud'hommes peut ordonner à votre
employeur de procéder au versement des
sommes qui vous sont dû plus s'intérêt
pour le retard calculer à pas du taux
d'intérêt légal c'est à dire que ce sera
majoré à 5% mais ici il a disparu déjà
pour aller le retrouver donc ça c'est
mort ok une procédure avec les comptes
soient saisis encore faut-il après qui a
de l'argent sur les mais il y aura il y
a pas d'argent c'est ça c'est sûr donc
c'est voilà le plus important pour vous
c'est que si le retard de paiement est
trop important vous pouvez obtenir la
rupture de votre contrat de travail et
elle sera alors qualifiée de
licenciement sans cause réelle ni
sérieux vous donnant ainsi droit au
versement d'indemnité vous ouvrons le
droit aux allocations chômage ça c'est
possible ce serait la meilleure des
solutions que la procédure soit
accélérée pour qu'il soit libéré de
cette situation d'aller tous les jours
dans un restaurant qui n'existe plus
donc là vous attendez là vous vous allez
continuer à y aller demain vous y allez
bah oui demain on y va quoi vous
travaillez quoi du lundi au samedi on
fait du mercredi au dimanche de 10h à
14h 10h à 14h30 et de 18h à 21h30
on respecte les horaires non mais
attendez vous êtes quoi incroyable cette
histoire vous êtes seul dans le
restaurant vous jouez aux cartes et vous
dites on attend vous attendez quoi qui
reviennent non non on attend que on nous
glisse qu'on puisse rentrer
excusez-moi parce que là il perd du
temps ils peuvent pas les chercher
ne peut prendre la responsabilité ni Le
Banni le procureur ni l'inspection du
travail ni l'administration puisque il y
a quelqu'un la France une fois de plus
on est quand même les rois des tocards
bien sûr bien sûr non mais c'est
surréaliste
d'une organisation syndicale pour elle
faire mais j'imagine qu'il y a pas de
syndicat donc voilà donc encore une fois
on marche avec tous les soirs on a des
histoires on se dit le pays il tourne
pas excusez-moi normalement ça c'est
cette histoire en deux heures elle est
réglée non mais excusez-moi je suis sûr
que dans un autre pays elle est réglée
en deux heures mais ici il y a des il y
a des il y a des gens partout il y a de
la paperasse partout et on fait rien
enfin c'est ça là c'est la partie
entre disparition volontaire disparition
inquiétante vivant ou mort donc
le reste voilà on s'en fout lui s'il est
parti vivre c'est pas vérifié
tous les hôpitaux
on le voit on voit les les les les
débits ils sont au téléphone a été borné
on voit que voilà il à mon avis il est
parti voilà et là là ça lui de de
peut-être de les aider si vous nous
regardent ce soir de vous aider de vous
libérer voilà et comme ça vous serez
libéré délivré tel la Reine des Neiges
la forêt il aurait pu faire dès le
départ bah oui bah bien sûr je compatis
d'autant plus qu'ici c'est l'inverse on
est payé sans travailler donc